the California condor the largest bird
in North America is making a comeback
from the brink of extinction in the
early 1980s there were only 22 left in
the world so scientists set out to
capture the remaining birds and create a
breeding program joy Benedict it's got a
behind-the-scenes look at how the LA Zoo
recently discovered a new technique
that's produced soaring results it is a
moment decades in the making as young
California condors get their first
glimpse of the open sky from inside this
flight pen at the bitter Creek National
Wildlife Refuge two hours north of Los
Angeles it's their final stop before
freedom Mike Clark is the Condor keeper
at the Los Angeles Zoo you letting your
kids go into the wild you know I let
them go into the big city but you have
to let them go that's the purpose of it
this is a California native bird this
belongs right in our backyard Clark has
been a key part of the Condor recovery
program for thirty years and this year
it hatched one heck of a milestone bird
number 1,000 reared his hand inside a
rocky cliff at Zion National Park with a
nine and a half foot wingspan it is the
largest bird in North America yet few
have ever seen one in 1982 there were 22
birds in the wild and by 84 that
breeding population had dropped to 9
seemingly destined for extinction
biologists captured all surviving birds
and the breeding program at the LA Zoo
was formed on the very beginning since
they were so few Birds we were really
careful we had every everyone was on
pins and needles you know we every egg
that hatched was worth its weight in
gold
at that time keepers used hand puppets
to raise them but the chicks became too
comfortable with humans their curiosity
is almost greater than their fear so the
keepers backed off now 43 cameras keep
watch over more than two dozen birds in
the wild condors might raise one check
every couple years but here when a
condor lays an egg keepers take it
prompt
the bird to lay another so Clark tried
something never done before
this is the adult female that reared
these two chicks he wanted to know if a
parent would foster more than one chick
so he approached a bird who knew him
well and here is a sexually mature
Burrus been breeding for years and years
and years raised tons of chicks with
another bird she sort of kind of got
attached to me because I was only one
that she was interacting so she fell in
love with you yes and I her it was a
wild success and this year for the first
time ever the chicks are all being
raised in pairs the zoo spends more than
half a million dollars a year trying to
save this species but the only Condor
visitors may see is Dolly who arrived
with a damaged wing they couldn't repair
so you guys spend all this money on the
California condor but you don't have a
condor exhibit at the zoo yeah how come
sewers are changing zoos have gone from
a place where you go to see animals to a
place that does conservation locally and
abroad and that brings us back this fall
day off to their new home in the
mountains where wild birds perched
nearby but so does danger just hoping
that you prepare them to survive since
the recovery program began the Condor
only has a fifty percent survival rate
it's still threatened by hunting lead
poisoning and hazards like powerlines
we call it the e perch the electric
perch if the birds land on it they get a
little shocked and they avoid it
Clark is training the birds to stay away
but most of the juveniles already do
because they're watching an older wiser
bird a mentor placed with them the
mentor he knows about the pole never
uses it none of them even try it so that
tells you how important the mentor is
and as a new flock is tagged and prepped
for release the keepers are hopeful can
you imagine walking out in your backyard
and seeing a bird with a nine and a half
foot wingspan sitting on your fence post
a dream that every year
it's closer to home as the lessons
learned give this shadowy feathered
flier a chance to not only sore but
survived for CBS this morning Saturday
joy Benedict Los Angeles awesome I
remember when the Condor was near
extinctions I grew up in California and
it was that time you just feared that we
were all going up and out well they're
back you're back you're here we're still
here the Condor really are oh my god
nine foot wingspan